please tell me what to do because this
is like I don't know what I'm looking at
where Kelly and shreya were roommates
and we are going to be switching jobs
tomorrow we both work at BuzzFeed but we
have very different jobs I'm a BuzzFeed
video producer I make videos I'm a
software engineer I spend most of my day
coding I wrote up a schedule for you
you're gonna pitch some video ideas
you're gonna have to find a co-producer
after that time to shoot your video
around 3:30 I said you start editing
your video I have a schedule for you
you're gonna have a daily stand-up
you're gonna get your tasks for the day
and then after that you're going to be
programming at the end of the day you
have to prepare a presentation for the
tech team PowerPoint excuse maybe this
is really happening it's happening this
is gonna be very bizarre I'm heading
into work right now con tired usually go
in like a half an hour later
to your first day of making videos my
first task of the day is to brainstorm
some ideas for my video just kind of
draw a little heading to work at 10:00
is great I feel so much more rested I
might switch careers that just for this
I'm the first one here I don't know the
first thing about her job that I think
is pretty important though we need to
change the copy edit for two big
products the status tracker and the
outdoor port that's something for
everyone we do so is that cool
I'm gonna take you an hour that's gonna
take me like 18 hours you will want to
collaborate with me so Jordan do you
want to be my co-producer for this video
I would do the wall eating octopuses
yeah I need to cast people you know that
Ned was Kelly's mentor so maybe he'll
say yes I'm going to have people eat
octopus while learning about octopuses
you know
yeah yes what's my dues want to bring
people in tell them it's an octopus
taste test yeah and then right when
they're like mmm this is so delicious be
like guess what did you know that
octopuses are the smartest animal now I
have to complete my task which is adding
time where do I add them sure I'll try
octopus would you eat octopus and prefer
not to do you want to be in a video
oh they're pretty serious have to do a
lot of rejection can you help me by
octopus by our solution I'm going into
the stage I need to go find us Neela
[Music]
singles back you should have allotted
like an hour
what's stressing you everything I have
that and that's it you've made a step so
this as a mock up is like okay this is
what we want the real thing to look like
we know that ending you she's got it we
just going to get it now is the journey
I need SD cards
does that look at that looks fine this
record any camera rolls okay
did you know have three hearts and nine
brains yes
also octopuses create fortresses using
crustacean shells I think I wasn't as
prepared for the octopus like the facts
as I should have been
I mostly cuz we were like setting up at
the last minute I think I've made a
breakthrough there is a where mi
document and I have never related to a
document more because I don't know where
I am found something called a V Slater
underscore UI which is user interface I
think that's what I'm supposed to fix or
to alter okay so you're close I found
that you have open it's actually back in
code I've heard of Python I've heard of
it
Monte Potter okay don't be rude oh this
is not back to code but it's a start so
it says 173 does that mean it's in line
173 of the head exactly but where's the
coke that fizzes they have three hearts
and nine brains
oh my god you can see the suction cups
so it turns out the suction cups have
photo receptors in them that are
responsible for making octopuses turn
different colors and I think she did a
bang-up job you know
I'm done practice I've to edit now I
found it more problematic thank you
there's more yeah so now I have to
figure out how to push this code I have
to open terminal and that looks
intimidating I'm right now starting to
copy everything over to the computer and
then I'm gonna start editing I'm going
to use the terminal move all of this
stuff I'm just not used to dragging and
dropping got one more step how this
takes for ever the next step is to
deploy this guy okay I am still editing
I've gotten through ten minutes of
footage it's ready it's ready it
literally has dark deploy okay okay
let's do it
deploy the code is not super clean
okay so now we gotta wait again
Wow and we got a deploy again there's
just one more step every time so this is
the moment this is the moment all right
this is the or Kelly's amazing code push
and this is after oh did it nailed it
days over it's only 329 no weird time
time to go
the last thing for me to do today is to
put together some sort of presentation I
didn't finish the video I got through
half of the video of editing you see my
word yes I like cut everything up wait
I'm so important together you really
would you really like did some [ __ ] I
have a newfound appreciation for
producers I give the same way about
engineers because I understand when
you're frustrated I get why now it just
I think we just know each other way
better now
I definitely agree but I'm glad the days
over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]